-Performing "Disaster,"
from his new album, "Superache,"
give it up for Conan Gray.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Let me just ♪
-♪ Set the scene ♪
♪ I just left the party at
Blake's and it's Halloween ♪
♪ Had the keys to my car
in my hand ♪
♪ But I didn't leave ♪
♪ 'Cause the potential of us ♪
♪ It was keepin' me up
all night long ♪
♪ I left a text
you won't read all night long ♪
♪ This could be a disaster ♪
♪ There's so many factors ♪
♪ Like, what if you freak out
and then we're losin' it all ♪
♪ At the critical chapter ♪
♪ Where I say I love you
and you don't say it after ♪
♪ This could be a disaster ♪
♪ Pedaling backwards ♪
♪ By sayin' that I'm drunk,
I really shouldn't have called ♪
♪ I'm a little bit plastered ♪
♪ You call me a liar,
now I'm fallin' in faster ♪
♪ This could be a disaster ♪
♪♪
♪ Disaster ♪
-♪ Let me just ♪
-♪ Lose my mind ♪
♪ Is it purely platonic
to call me, like, every night ♪
♪ You know Ashley believes
that there's something ♪
♪ Between you and I ♪
♪ But if I'm readin' it wrong,
man, it'd be better off ♪
♪ If I die, oh ♪
♪ And if you're readin'
the text all night long ♪
♪ This could be a disaster ♪
♪ There's so many factors ♪
♪ Like, what if you freak out
and then we're losin' it all ♪
♪ At the critical chapter ♪
♪ Where I say I love you
and you don't say it after ♪
♪ This could be a disaster ♪
♪ Pedaling backwards ♪
♪ By sayin' that I'm drunk,
I really shouldn't have called ♪
♪ I'm a little bit plastered ♪
♪ You call me a liar,
now I'm fallin' in faster ♪
♪ This could be a disaster ♪
♪♪
♪ Disaster ♪
♪ Maybe I'm mistaken ♪
♪♪
♪ You're not mine for taking ♪
♪ Maybe I'm mistaken ♪
♪♪
♪ Maybe I just made it up ♪
♪ Messed it up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]